a message to young conservationists play  in the forest and preserve it every year  seventy thousand square kilometers of  forest are lost worldwide  more and more children never get a  chance to play in the woods a German  group called ver de vets wants to change  that the initiative organizes nature  trips for kids  [Music]  they learn to make fire without a  lighter and how to identify plants and  follow animal spores this footprint was  left by a wild boar  [Music]  children should take the time to play  fool around and get dirty if children  get to know and have fun in the forest  they might appreciate it and protect it  later  [Music]  do you like that if you're also doing  your bit tell us about it visit our  website or send us a tweet hashtag doing  your bit we share your stories  [Music]